the Joe Rogan experience is there any
Hunts that you were like really
interested in doing that you haven't
done yet I really want to do a spot in
stock mountain lion hunt oh Jesus oh
yeah you want a spot and stalk the thing
that spots and stalks yes where you
gonna do that I don't know so I think in
the Dakotas and in Oregon there's a
decent chance for it there's a decent
chance because the population density
population density and then I think
Oregon and I want to say South Dakota
don't allow dog hunts Oh
so Oregon's weird that's dense Oregon's
a weird place that's dense footage
I mean foliage yeah yeah that would be
hard I think it'd be hard you know what
though I want that kind of check those
are the things that really get me like
way deep inside you know we were talking
about this last night you're gonna give
yourself a while like three weeks like
I'm thinking in my head I need a couple
weeks to make it happen Wow and I man
look I'm a new hunter mm-hmm but I'm
doing as much research as possible
talking to all the right people and when
it happens it happens so I would really
want to make it happen what's the
process for that you get a tag you go
into the backcountry and are you gonna
be sac are you gonna just sleep in the
woods like that'd be my that would be
what I want to do mmm is solo
Biffy alright solo or maybe one other
guy I think more than that you're gonna
have so much presence in those woods
you're never gonna see a cat yeah so how
the [ __ ] do you find a cat when you're
by yourself I think you got to cut a
track or find a kill mmm so your plan is
to get yourself in an area where they're
at mm-hmm
a lot of stars got a lineup yeah but
that's part of the that's part of the
cool part about hunting it's not just
killing right right then well that's a
that's probably one of the most
difficult hunts you can go on damn right
which and for me like growing up in
Southern California having seen a
mountain lion when I was younger I've
just had a a like a real deep feeling
about mountain lions I think they're
incredible animals and I think it would
be a really really special thing to pit
my training and brain with a bow against
a cat like and eat it yes
that's gotta be weird eat it sitting
down there eating a cat that you killed
with a bow and arrow it's gonna be
really cool yeah if it's if I'm able to
make it happen at some point but you
want mean you're gonna get a lot of
meals out of that cat I think they're
huge that's you dude a little cat like
the one sounded down here they're like a
hundred and ten hundred twenty pounds
the ones up in BC or like two hundred do
they really get that big yeah two
hundred yeah that's a big cat yeah it's
a weird animal that just sort of coexist
with us you seen that photo that I have
out there of the ones why the how cool
it's Hollywood sign that's a real photo
it does it looks big it's so cool it
looks fake but that's from a camera trap
that is a giant cat that lives in
Griffith Park right by the Hollywood
sign dude cats are cats are wild
that is a I mean that is a crazy place
for it to live though because it's
literally on top of people oh yeah and
the good luck finding a deer up there
for that reason that motherfucker's
jacking them all eating everything and
dogs and cats and probably kids if some
kid [ __ ] up but you let your kid off
the leash yeah I mean it's just a weird
animal to coexist with people in these
sort of semi urban settings like
Griffith Park but it's only weird
because of the setting and because we're
not used to it
like we've coexisted with these things
for so long and now it's weird because
we've separated the last few generations
so how deeply how far away are you from
planning this out probably a couple of
years if I'm guessing correctly how does
that work because it's hard to get a tag
or no because I want to make sure that
my skills and my ability are up to snuff
where I'm comfortable doing that and
pulling it off so it's right now just a
thought like like a plan
absolutely put it on the books for 2023
or something like that something like
that
[Applause]